12月の204日日曜日23:40
皆さん
イエイイエイアイ
今日は何とクリスマスイブそしてもうしばらくするとクリスマスになりますそこでです
ねうん2月論に中4日の夜の9時から12月の25のアンジまでのこの6時間のことを
性の6時間と言われているわけでございましたあーーカップルとかね恋人とか夫婦とか
こう言っちゃい茶するはラブリーのね
何
に育ったんだと思うんですけど
最近じゃねそうですねそういう日なんで逆に今ならオフ会開けるんじゃねっていう
桶川階です以前なんか急に岡奈美のオフ会開いたら100人ができちゃったんですけど
も
逆にもきょうみたいなメッツ雨降ってますよめちゃくちゃ
山って感じなんですけど目覚め売ってる中のこの24dec の生の6柄のど真ん中
ですよ西7グッズ
彼女真ん中になったねぇまぁから公園で一時間だけオフ会を開きますこのクリスマスの
ど真ん中にオフ会開くと何人来てくれるのか検証していこうと思います
グルーこの日です結局をなった猫ないと思うんで予想だけちょっとたとえ打ってみます
か犯人グラティあるでいいレベルよる30人30人さん
ずに俺はこれは信じるよみんな
50人セミリーネうんみんなこんな知る時に撮って象瀬方が入ってるからそれでも
さっそく釣れちゃいましょう一応場所がもう決まったり心すぐ行けるので上でますオフ
会します
場所は静岡県静岡市の駿府城公園の県庁の近くにある橋の上です今から12時50分
までやっているのでみんな来てねー未成年の方はごめんなさい参加できます
んちょっとした上流が思ってあまりましょうというわけで乱れに淫れたクリスマス末端
の中粮この天気の悪い中で何人の方がオフ会に来てくれるのか検証してきたいと思い
ますではいこ
以前と書いてみた入ってると深い会場に到着しました
ここでまだ待ってくれてるんですけどまだ誰も来てませんがここは1時間待ちます
最低一に減ってきた
始まって本当大北かーいっ
短パン無理とか言っ
tan
パンツを頼りに作っ
矢部あと2分でクリスマスイブが割れこれ絶対でこういうのど真ん中にいねえっ絶対
まぁリツイートガッテン超えました
おおなんかみんななーんもんってます地図をかずるいぞ
信子はいえでき作ってる姉からきょうつけてありがとうあっぱれだね静岡げっアームズ
カスタムポイントしかねぇ
初のオフ会0に来るかこれはダイアの朝くらいに求めたいと思います今日始めたとおっ
回くらいやってる
矢部02んって結構歴史に残るでインテル編
応援サッカーの30人とか言ってうわっ
ずう月25日でございますメリクリします名義レーティングませんここに国会時間が
45年になりました
[音楽]
認知との本意を消防車セット伏せスター
誰ビゼーかもしれないえっ
でございます
これで1
で抑えにいってくれたんですかこれ
yeah
rar
can you do nao
サッカーからずさあ何言ってくれましたいやまずで02かと思ったら bearer
初人目が来てくれました
teruha
amaran
can you do
あえて触れません
準備目になりました
uh
犬いろいろは22人とする時
ございます13人目では確か
earth あかん買ってきました
いいこれええかいたんだったりスターデー
me
今22m えっ恋ノウスいーねーがーる
re re
ええええええ
残り15分です人数外れた日だった
じゃあねー re you doing
ちなみに残り時間あと10分切っちゃってますよ
もうちょっと粘ってみましょう渡欧
[音楽]
day 4さあ
2 e 1
終了 me
uh
では集計していこうと思います
22位
ファンって
bej
スーツ
導入だ treasure
[音楽]
me
deai
ana あああっ
すげー
いってんじゃねーはぁ
dere jan